- remarkable tie restaurants but only
one can continue through to the next
round
okay right I brought both Russians here
to give you an opportunity a unique
opportunity to really cook like you've
never cooked before
now I'm Jim I saw the dish it didn't
look the most appetizing having been to
your restaurant and seen the style in
which you deliver food it was a little
bit of a surprise to see something so
basic as that I tasted the chicken and
bang it was just yeah it was amazing
however at this station the competition
this round is not won on a single dish
nom Jim Sigrid Ines no experienced food
like that absolutely love that food
haggis in a Thai restaurant doesn't even
sound right but for you to turn into
something that goes very few Russians
can do that anywhere
mango tree the fascinating thing with
you Mars you're not even you know even
from Thailand you seem to have this
magic with Thai cuisine that is a is a
gift I'm a mango trees at its best is
untouchable send in a secret diner
absolutely blown away with that food I
mean really really blown away with that
food to do the booths and again at this
stage of the competition I admire the
balls it was sweet
it was delicious and authentic how could
I criticize that how could I look at
that dish and tell you how to do it
better I didn't have to the first time
there's competition I just came back
you've left with a very tough decision
the restaurant going through to the
semi-final is
nom Jim congratulations
welcome yes to Tommy
why don't you with your touch and the
mountain experience you have with Thai
cuisine I know you've got more coming
very disappointed you know I'm stifling
our de North and the team and our
customers down but you know that's the
way it goes you know wish them all the
luck pissed off at the moment some will
never tell me before I'm good and I'm
insidious competition so it's mean so
much for me it's a bit mind-boggling
first we were all very very proud and a
little bit shops and standardly